um what we we obviously you've talked a
lot about your street [__] but I'm I'm
curious like on a day-to-day basis what
are you into man you watch Netflix or
you [__] playing video games into
sports like what are you into uh yeah
I'll be playing I'll be playing I'll be
playing the game cuz sometime fortnite
cuz 2K fortnite's fire yeah [__] Fork
they brought the OG zero build though
cuz I don't play the build version
though cuz I don't know how to build you
know how to build no I just play Zero
build and I go crazy on it zero build
you is only killing right yeah just
killing yeah those Builders are weird
yeah I don't know to [__] build some
[__] like experts cuz [__] shit's
all the way up in the sky built a
[__] skyscraper in like two seconds
like what the [__] so when I play
fortnite I play with my kid and he hates
me cuz like he'll watch me and I'll be
[__] I'll just go to that Treehouse
that's like real high up and I'll just
chill and wait for everybody to kill
each other you know what I'm saying and
then once it's like the last 10 I be
like okay let me go down here you what
they call a camper yes you camp out I'm
a camper that's what he calls me I'm I'm
a Noob and a camper yeah yeah yeah I got
we got I got a resolution for those
though what do you do you find him yeah
I'mma find the camper cuz bomb your
[__]
Jesus he said he's goingon to bomb the
campers um so and you play 2K what your
team on
2K
um it depends cuz I don't really got
like no specific team that I just like
pick I go off whoever like want playing
pick were you like a Laker fan yeah I'm
really like I'm really like a James
Harden fan cuz I I was like a big
Rockets fan when Coes in the Rockets
then left and he heard my heart cuz I'm
really like a James Harden fan but yeah
how do you feel the Lakers are you a
Clipper fan now since Harden's there nah
cuz once once once once he uh left the
Rockets cuz I was already like you know
on the day homies I was already getting
over him and he's been a lot less fun to
watch since he left the Rockets yeah he
left the rockets and broke my heart
already already like I was getting over
him so you kind of a Rockets fan I was
when he was there he they got a little
Squad right now who the Clippers no the
Rockets who they got they got some young
guys they got Jaylen green they got um
Jabari Smith they got Dylan Brooks they
got Fred Van Fleet heard heard cut oh
yeah Fred go crazy they got a little
Squad going over there it's definitely
they just smoked the Lakers by 30 all
them names was cool but all them names
ain't big enough to do nothing though
they smoked the Lakers by 30 last night
but ad was out exactly yeah I Ain I
haven't been watching that [__] cuz on
the D homies I ain't been watching no
Sports this Seas I know you're tight
with Deshawn Jackson you guys are from
the same Hood uh what's it like having
like a guy like djck you know know it's
SP on the dead homies that's he's a
legend Hall of Famer future Hall of
Famer for sure future Hall of Famer you
going crazy on game that's bro dead
homies I I know he was doing the what
was the name of his label you could
probably help me was it ja jackpot I was
going to say jackpot yeah I know he was
doing that he got the jackpot [__]
rolling you ever try to sign you nah nah
he probably regrets not trying to sign
you h no but he had like you know legit
reason on the dead homies on C that made
a lot of sense so I'm G what was his
reason well you know you know some
little inside [__] I'm G it it was a
legit reason that's fair yeah yeah
that's fair legit reason for sure for
sure uh you just signed a big deal
congratulations yeah um I saw I saw uh
it's Gein right yeah shout out to good
talk shout my guy Johnny shes okay um
what was the bidding war like for you
though cuz it had to be like yeah it
wasn't like they're the only people
trying to sign you n yeah it was all
type of people tapping how many people
were trying to sign you Empire [__]
they always tapping in who from Empire
was trying to talk to Gentry [__] I
don't remember no [__] name just tell
me I [__] got to go through my text
hey I'm with you from with you hey I'm
with you yeah so everybody everybody was
trying to get at you yeah for sure so
what made you especially like after like
I posted cuz everybody thought I was
signing A Wack cuz I took that picture
of wack and The Wack conversation like
kept popping up but after I posted like
I'm not signing nobody that [__] like on
my St yeah I think I I I I heard like I
thought that you might have been signed
with whack as well yeah everybody
thought that so after like I posted like
on my story like I'm not s I'm getting
my story like be rolling G of views so
what made you choose though Gein and uh
good talk those guys cuz they were just
like you know everything they touch turn
to go cuz I mean they just like you know
they was talking right have you heard of
that Mexican OT obviously that your
label mate he just got a gold plaque
yeah he going crazy me and uh I went to
Houston with that Mexican OT and we went
hog hunting we was murdered hogs out of
a out of a helicopter I want to hunt out
a helicopter out of a [__] helicopter
me and OT was [__] we had the [__]
AR-15s that's sick and we smoked we
probably killed like 10 pigs great yeah
there's a vlog coming soon it was a good
time man you should you know what I
think that people like hunting I never
was like a hunter ever this the first
time I ever hunted but I was like oh
this is kind of like you know if you
want to get some aggression out just go
helicopter though that's like kind of
like you know you'll think you'll start
with the simple just you know on the
ground so we did that you like you
trophied up cuz that's what you call
Trophy and up cuz you really trophied up
straight to the helicopter and then at
night we uh we did like a 2 a.m. hunt
where we had like night vision goggles
on and we like stocked a bunch of pigs
and then we found them and just put them
down BL day [__] did y'all like go go go
go take them in and eat bacon n we just
left them there oh cuz they're pest
they're like uh they're like pest to the
area they're they're do you eat pork I
love the pork okay do you hell yeah
[__] the swine is the vine I'm black
[__] I eat pork [__] first of all a
lot of black people will say they don't
eat the swine no pork on my Fork I hear
that all the time I got my best friend
in the world is black and he will not
touch mine yeah that's true but they
they they really like deep down they
really like want to do this [__] I don't
know why you wouldn't eat pig it's so
good and a lot of people that be saying
they don't eat pork on the day homie
they get byself and really do it up
listen you know turkey bacon ain't good
that [__] bunk run that [__] is
trash get you some real [__] bacon
come on girl the real deal some pork
chops come on some ham with the red
rooster on it imagine that's the only
hot sauce I eat too Red I can't eat no
other really hot sauce like really so
likeed straight Red Rooster and Tapo
Tapo solid I I like Tabasco on my eggs I
don't eat nothing else cuz like what's
that sauce that come with the Green Top
cuz on a dead Green Top you talking
about Tabasco no no uh on a dead homie
just got uh with the Green Top cuz it's
like red it's like clear come in the
clear container that's Tabasco sauce no
it's not Tobasco it has a green lid it's
like it's tall though it's like a tall
can it's like tall it's clear the sauce
is like
red I'm going to show you on a DI no not
Tabasco not this srra on CR Sriracha
Sriracha Sriracha no I don't eat that
yeah Sriracha is gas I Ain going lie
honestly like I can [__] with any hot
sauce I feel like as long if I open the
fridge if I'm at someone's house and
they make food and I'm like what you got
is whatever they got I'm like I got to
[__] with it yeah cuz I can't do that
bro I'm picky as [__] on the D are you
picky with everything you eat hell yeah
like will you eat oysters yeah so you
okay well you're not that picky that's
jail that's jail food though bro they
sell oysters on the jail list well I
mean listen I always if someone says
they eat oysters they can't be that
picky cuz the real picky [__]
oysters that you put that in the spread
on the day I'm us do it up oysters are
good so what is like something most
people eat that you won't [__] with uh
that most people it's a lot of [__] that
most people eat I don't eat tacos what
the [__] well it's really like the it's
the corn shell I don't eat the shell but
you do flour I don't yeah I do a flower
[__] you don't like corn tortillas no I
don't eat pickles onions ketchup mustard
mayonnaise so my burger just like got
meat and cheese on it that's it yeah I'm
like a simple eater cuz you're like my
kid he's [__] 10
simp we go to the drivethru and it's
like cheeseburger plain yeah plain
cheeseburger so no ketchup no onions no
pickles no mayonnaise no mustard none of
that [__] just like might throw some
bacon on your how do you eat a hot dog
it's just
straight uh put some uh put some pork
and beans on it D put some pork and
beans on it with some cheese on cripp
and crunch some hot chips on it okay and
do it do it up like that but no sauce no
sauce you're not a sauce guy unless it's
red rooster yeah unless it's red rooster
but that don't go on no hot dog no no no
no it doesn't I mean it could go you
never know you do that [__] on the D me
you nasty hey you're going to have a
rough day at the uh the restroom for
sure yeah damn no tacos and you are from
La yeah [__] the taco trucks are amazing
we have the best taco trucks in the
country here yeah I yeah but you eat a
flour taco yeah I eat a flour one though
or you eat a burrito yeah I eat a
burrito CU with just like meat and
cheese and that [__] and rice you like
Pastore the stuff they shave off with
the with the pineapple on the top no I
don't get that just do a Sal
yeah you r or like sometimes chicken or
I might feeling fancy I might mix you
might do both might do both give me both
give me the steak you you [__] with like
seafood though
right um if it's like fried like fried
shrimp and like C but you don't have
like a cold shrimp cocktail n hell no
damn it got to be like a certain way
it's got to be deep fried yeah okay I
respect that they have oysters in jail
hell yeah oysters macro wait how the
[__] did the oysters come in jail they
in a
can not in a [__] can they come like
in a [__] uh they can come in a they
some prisons like they serve them
different some coming in pouch and some
coming in low can [__] too some do com I
would not want jail oysters no it's like
the regular oysters from the streets
like you go in the grocery store that
same brand in prison bro I like oysters
on a half shell on ice and then you
slurp it oh like you like the real
oyster yeah I'm talking about like
oysters bro at the grocery store bro I
never had those trench [__] [__] bro
like I see that grocery store oysters
grocery store oysters with the noodles
you [__] with
sardines sardines that's like the fish
in the can sardines oh yeah oh yeah yeah
not like that though cuz but I had them
in the spread before a couple times on
the de homies